monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs merci pour cette
invitation pour prier brièvement
l'introduction donc en tant que
directeur scientifique environnement
d'inrae j'ai dans mon portefeuille de
compétences là le pilotage pour
l'établissement de 4 grands domaines qui
sont très interconnectés et qui font
écho à vos préoccupations le premier
c'est celui de l'adaptation et de
l'atténuation face au changement
climatique notamment pour le domaine
agricole mais aussi pour les écosystèmes
forestiers qui sont un objet
d'importance pour une rail le second les
questions de biodiversité parce qu'on ne
peut pas imaginer une dynamique
d'adaptation sans intégrer les
dimensions de biodiversité la gestion
durable des ressources en eau et en sol
ça fait partie du débat d'aujourd'hui et
puis un point un peu transversal sur
l'évaluation et la gestion des risques
notamment liés au phénomène naturel mais
aussi aux pression anthropiques alors
pour un institut comme inrae qui vous le
savez sans doute est né il y a
maintenant trois ans le 1er janvier 2020
à part la fusion de l'INRA et dear
Stella
on a réussi à réunir dans un même
établissement des compétences qui nous
permettent d'aborder la question de
l'eau depuis finalement les
précipitations qui tombent à la surface
des terres émergées jusqu'aux
écoulements vers la mer ce qu'on appelle
souvent l'eau bleue et puis bien sûr la
dimension ouverte qui vous intéresse
particulièrement dans le propos
d'aujourd'hui qui est cette eau
finalement qu'on va retrouver via les
précipitations dans les sols et qui au
travers des plantes va repartir vers
l'atmosphère par un phénomène qu'on
appelle l'évapo-transpiration et c'est
ce cycle de l'eau via les plantes qui
permet la photosynthèse et la production
de matière vivante qui est à la base de
tous les écosystèmes bien sûr les
agroécosystèmes pour une race est un
sujet très important mais aussi
l'ensemble des écosystèmes naturels s'il
n'y a pas de flux d'eau il n'y a pas de
vie bien sûr ça tout le monde le sait
pas de photosynthèse et pas de
production alimentaire notamment donc
dans ce contexte de tension sur les
ressources en eau et de possibles voire
probable diminution de ces ressources à
des moments critiques de la production
pour nous l'enjeu principal il est de
mieux comprendre le cycle de l'eau et de
mieux j'allais dire le modéliser vous
avez évoqué monsieur le Président les
projections notamment sur sur le futur
et je voudrais citer ici peut-être on y
reviendra un exercice mené avec le
ministère de la transition écologique et
d'autres partenaires sur ce qu'on
appelle explore de sur la projection de
la disponibilité des ressources en eau
des écoulements à l'échéance de la
moitié du siècle et ce projet est en
cours c'est une revisite d'un exercice
antérieure et il démontre que a priori
les ressources en dômes exécoulement
vont profondément diminuer dans les
années qui viennent le deuxième point
c'est penser l'agriculture de demain
reconcevoir l'agriculture et les
systèmes agricoles pour à la fois
s'adapter aux conditions nouvelles liés
au changement climatique et contribuer
puisque c'est aussi une des missions de
l'agriculture à l'atténuation du
changement climatique en réduisant les
émissions liées aux activités agricoles
et pour cela notre établissement
s'appuie en grande partie sur les outils
de l'agroécologie c'est à dire
reconcevoir les systèmes ne pas dans un
un grand nombre de cas persister dans un
système qui a atteint ses limites
notamment du fait mais pas uniquement de
à la raréfaction de ressources en eau à
certains de phases critiques du cycle
des plantes notamment en été pour
pouvoir à la fois favoriser
l'infiltration de l'eau ralentir le
cycle de l'eau qui permet d'augmenter la
réserve utile en eau des sols de
diversifier les productions agricoles à
l'échelle des bassins des territoires
pour avoir notamment des pratiques et
des récoltes ou des cultures qui soient
plus économes en eau et aussi de
repenser l'ensemble du système
alimentaire la chaîne alimentaire
puisque l'adaptation de l'agriculture
notamment par rapport au changement
climatique ce n'est pas qu'une question
de production faut pas se limiter à ce
qui se passe dans les parcelles dans les
exploitations c'est l'ensemble du
système alimentaire l'ensemble des
semaines de valeurs qui doit s'adapter
et donc au travers à la fois des outils
de l'agroécologie de la transformation
des systèmes de production c'est pas une
simple adaptation incrémentale on est
vraiment on parle de reconception des
systèmes c'est aller vers des systèmes
qui soient plus économes en un an
notamment en eau mais pas uniquement
c'est aussi le cas sanitaire et des
engrais dont on sait qu'il y a une forte
dépendance pour ces derniers par rapport
au commerce international et puis aussi
être capable de se projeter dans un
avenir différent puisque il y aura des
régions de France il faut quand même s'y
attendre de manière très forte ou la
disponibilité en eau sera fortement
réduite et donc l'agriculture telle
qu'on la connaît les activités qu'on les
connaît ne pourront pas se perpétuer
indéfiniment donc il faut anticiper et
c'est pour ça qu'on travaille avec les
acteurs qu'ils soient des acteurs
académiques comme nos collègues du BRGM
du CNRS des acteurs de terrain comme les
Chambres d'agriculture les instituts
techniques mais aussi des agences de
l'État agence de l'eau office français
de la biodiversité pour se projeter à
l'échelle des territoires sur ces futurs
possibles dans un monde où la ressource
en eau est devenue plus rare et donc de
travailler aussi avec nos collègues de
des pouvoirs publics sur l'appui au
politique publique pour notamment
imaginer les scénarios de partage de
l'eau l'eau est un bien commun que l'on
peut à un moment donné capter pour un
usage privé mais il faut qu'à un moment
donné ce retour vers le bien commun se
fasse et donc imaginez des transitions
où chacun trouve son compte et peut-être
pour terminer mon propos monsieur le
Président si vous voulez je continuerai
après s'il y a des questions
imaginez en fait que
on ne peut pas continuer comme on l'a
fait jusqu'à présent et puis que il y a
des clés il y a aussi des possibilités
de développement nouveaux associés à
cette nouvelle façon de voir la gestion
des ressources en eau des transitions à
l'échelle des territoires qui doivent
concerner tout le monde et il ne
faudrait pas imaginer que on puisse
continuer sans qu'il y ait un moment
donné une transition et la transition
elle peut être on va dire vécue et
anticiper collectivement mais elle peut
malheureusement être subi sous le choc
de catastrophes et là si on n'a pas
anticipé on est vraiment dans une
situation critique et qui serait à mon
avis dommageable pour l'instant de la
société et pas uniquement pour
l'agriculture je retiendrai là pour ces
propos introductifs
merci Monsieur Thibault
merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames Messieurs les signatrices
sénateur
d'abord merci d'avoir organisé cette
table ronde et sur ce point c'est un
enjeu hyper fort pour la direction de un
des premiers enjeux si d'arriver en
parler autour de nous et vous l'avez
très bien mis dans votre introduction on
a du mal à sensibiliser nos concitoyens
sur le fait que le sujet de l'eau est un
vrai sujet et que ça va devenir de plus
en plus un sujet et bon l'été 2022 avec
la crise sècheresse a été une sorte
d'électrochoc pour un certain nombre de
d'entre nous et de nos concitoyens
si je le dis d'une façon très simple ça
a été une crise
presque inconnue jusque là mais qui ne
fait que préfiguré ce qu'on va voir dans
le domaine hydrologique dans quelques
années donc après les scientifiques le
disent vachement mieux que moi avec des
courbes des chiffres etc mais ce qu'on a
vécu cet été est-ce qu'on va vivre de
manière récurrente en termes de
disponibilité en lot d'ici 15-20 ans et
donc si tu n'alertes qu'il faut prendre
et pour nous aider à nous adapter et là
il y a un mois important l'adaptation on
n'est plus dans l'atténuation seule
c'est-à-dire que nous n'avons pas réussi
au niveau mondial à prendre les mesures
et les décisions qu'il fallait pour
bloquer changement climatique donc le
changement climatique il arrive pas que
à l'autre bout du monde dans 50 ans mais
chez nous aussi et ce qu'on commence à
avoir les manifestations il y a un des
premiers effets du changement climatique
c'est sur l'eau et donc il faut qu'on
apprenne à adapter nos modèles pour
faire face à ces changements cet été
700 communes on a près de 36000 communes
en France 700 communes ont été en
rupture d'eau
ça nous fait redécouvrir des choses
qu'on avait oublié que quand on ouvre
l'eau du robinet l'eau elle coule elle
est potable il y a pas de problème mais
en fait cette eau elle est pas infinie
et la gestion de l'eau en été ça n'est
pas qu'un sujet agricole c'est bien un
sujet pour l'ensemble des usages et là
on retrouve et on reprend il faut
reprendre conscience que cette ressource
elle est finie il faut la partager et
l'objectif c'est pas de partager de
l'eau qui n'existe pas mais bien de
partager l'eau qui existe et donc d'être
sur des vrais chiffres et d'organiser la
façon dont on va organiser au mieux
l'ensemble de nos usages pour faire face
à ses besoins donc 700 communes en
rupture d'eau alors c'est pas forcément
cette sans commune où il y avait plus
d'eau robinet parce que comme on a des
opérateurs
très bien organisés et des communes qui
ont fait le travail qu'il fallait en
fait on a eu beaucoup de camions qui
sont baladés sur nos routes cet été et
qu'on remplit les châteaux d'eau pour
éviter que les gens pour que les gens
puissent avoir de l'eau Rob mais donc
cette sans rupture d'alimentation sur
des communes tout ou partie des communes
avec au passage monsieur le sénateur une
corrélation très forte avec les communes
qui ne sont pas rentrées dans des
intercommunalités
on a les chiffres on pourra vous les
présenter et c'est un point important
c'est pas que c'est moins bien quand on
est une commune toute seule c'est que
quand on a pas fait de travaux
d'interconnexion ou de sécurisation ou
de fiabilisation mais quand on a un
problème on sait pas réagir on réagit
pas pareil et le seul moyen c'est de
mettre des camions sur les routes pour
transporter cette eau et ça c'est un
point important c'est pas pour le
plaisir qu'on comporte le sujet du
transfert là aux EPCI affiscalité propre
c'est un moyen aussi d'être plus
résilient bon je fais la parenthèse mais
voilà
oui oui c'est un sujet sensible et je
veux dire on est aussi là pour dire les
choses sur lesquelles il faut qu'on
travaille
ce que je voulais dire aussi c'est que
nos systèmes il a tenu bon cet été je
veux dire je pense que cette crise la
même crise on l'aurait eu il y a 10 ans
je suis pas sûr qu'on aurait tenu pareil
on avait anticipé la gestion de crise on
avait des cartes on avait on a partagé
très tôt depuis le mois de mai juin sur
les cartes d'anticipation on les préfet
avait préparé des arrêtés préfectoraux
cadres sécheresse enfin le système était
pas parfait mais il a tenu bon et donc
c'est un truc qui marche par contre
enfin moi ce que je dis maintenant
souvent autour de moi faut qu'on fasse
un peu attention au syndrome nucléaire
c'est à dire que on est persuadé que
tout va bien et que tout ça va tenir
et que donc il y aura jamais de problème
en fait
on joue un peu avec le feu dans le
domaine de l'eau c'est à dire qu'on a
fait des investissements énormes
après-guerre jusque dans les années 80
sur l'eau potable jusque dans les années
2000 sur l'assainissement avec un
patrimoine qui est très important et un
patrimoine que nous n'entretenons pas
assez je dis nous au niveau global on a
une sorte de tyrannie du prix de l'eau
qui s'exerce ou un élu est considéré
comme meilleur s'il a un service
minimaliste avec un prix de l'eau faible
plutôt qu'un vrai service avec un prix
lot un peu plus élevé et donc du coup ça
nous conduit tous à sous-investir et
sous-entretenir dans le patrimoine et ça
se voit pas au début
comme sur le parc nucléaire ça se voit
pas on peut retarder un certain nombre
de choses et puis un jour ça collapse et
donc le but c'est que ça collapse pas
dans le système de l'eau et donc
aujourd'hui on est un moment où il faut
qu'on recommence à investir plus dans
l'entretien de notre patrimoine donc
après on peut le prendre par le bout des
fuites les rendements des réseaux mais
en fait le vrai sujet c'est comment on
entretient ce patrimoine extraordinaire
qui nous permet d'avoir de l'eau au
robinet alors votre question c'était sur
les solutions
alors en quelques mots il faut connaître
pour être solide sur nos décisions pour
pouvoir investir il faut connaître donc
il faut c'est vrai pour les réseaux
c'est vrai pour les fuites mais c'est
vrai aussi pour le partage de l'eau donc
on a quand même fait des gros efforts de
connaissances après c'est à lui qu'il
faut poser les questions sur explore 2
export 2070 les rapports du GIEC enfin
je veux dire il y a quand même plein de
choses qui nous permettent de savoir
s'il y a plus d'eau moins d'eau de l'eau
moins disponible de l'eau répartie pas
pareil et mais en fait une disponibilité
au moment où on en a besoin qui baisse
et c'est ça qui faut retenir donc il
faut connaître il faut s'appuyer sur ses
connaissances après il faut planifier
donc dans le domaine de l'eau on a quand
même une longue histoire de
planification donc tous les bassins ont
fait du plan d'adaptation changement
climatique on a un système qui s'appelle
isdage schéma directeur d'aménagement de
gestion de l'eau par grand bassin
versant porté par les agences de l'eau
qui permet tous les 6 ans de regarder
l'eau qu'on a en quantité en qualité de
se fixer des objectifs s'ils ont après
et de regarder ce qu'il faut faire pour
y arriver et donc ces âges
ça veut dire c'est le socle qui nous
permet de voir ce qu'il faut faire et
comment faire puis là très récemment on
a lancé les chantiers de planification
écologique enfin c'est la première mise
qui a lancé les chantiers planification
écologique le premier chantier dans ces
chantiers c'est le chantier de l'eau
on a eu une très large concertation
pendant les quatre derniers mois au sein
du Comité national de l'eau dans les
comités de bassin
des réunions de restitution donc là
maintenant tout ça est dans la main des
ministres en tout cas ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que il y a une pleine
propositions dans tout un tas de
domaines et qui a du travail de devant
nous pour mettre en œuvre l'ensemble de
ces choses mais on prend bien que c'est
pas moi qui vais annoncer quoi que ce
soit maintenant
après sur les solutions en quelques mots
clés et puis vous poserez des questions
sur ce qui vous intéresse le premier
point c'est que l'eau n'est pas un sujet
national c'est un sujet territorial et
il faut qu'on fasse attention aux vraies
fausses bonnes solutions du genre il y a
autant d'eau en tout sur la France donc
il suffit de les stocker pour l'amener
au bon endroit vous avez des parties du
territoire où il y aura moins d'eau et
en été et en hiver
et donc moins d'eau tout court vous avez
des endroits où il y aura trop d'eau
l'hiver ce qu'il faut à peu près l'été
enfin vous allez avoir toutes les
situations et puis si vous avez de l'eau
qui est au nord de la France vous allez
pas réussir à l'utiliser dans le bas de
la France ou inversement donc c'est un
sujet territorial et donc il faut
s'organiser au niveau territorial
ce qu'on dit nous au ministère
aujourd'hui un territoire une
gouvernance ce système il faut il est
transversal donc il y a pas une eau
agricole une eau pour l'eau potable une
eau pour l'industrie une eau pour
l'énergie c'est bien une ressource en
eau et quand on fait aujourd'hui la
somme des besoins exprimés c'est
supérieur à l'eau réellement disponible
en tout cas certaines parties de l'année
et donc il faut que chaque territoire
s'organise pour choisir ce qui veut
faire dans les territoires
moi mon sentiment là dedans c'est que
les élus ont un rôle essentiel dans le
système ça doit pas être celui qui a le
plus d'argent ou celui qui est le plus
fort qui va
obtenir l'eau qu'il veut c'est bien les
élus qui doivent organiser leur
territoire et organiser ce partage de
l'eau et puis définir ce qu'on a envie
de faire son territoire histoire des
bassines enfin je veux dire quand c'est
pas accepté dans le territoire ben je
veux dire c'est quand même le bazar
assez vite donc un sujet territorial
transversal et il faut une gouvernance
dans chaque territoire après
je l'ai déjà dit mais je le redis faut
répartir l'eau qui existe
un de nos problèmes aujourd'hui dans le
domaine de l'eau c'est qu'on fantasme
encore sur les autorisations théoriques
qu'on a pu donner il y a 20 ans
notamment dans le domaine agricole mais
pas que donc si on autorise des volumes
qui n'existent que quand tout va bien se
passer qu'il va y avoir plein d'eau
plein de précipitations et que c'est le
seul moment où on aura assez tôt et donc
en fait on aura la quantité disponible
en fait quand on n'aura pas besoin parce
que l'eau sera tombé par ailleurs
naturellement
et que derrière on ne répartit pas le
réel qu'on a dans les territoires 8
années sur 10 en fait on y conduit à
gérer l'eau par la crise et c'est un peu
ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que vous délivrez des autorisations
théoriques d'eau selon la situation la
meilleure possible et après chaque fois
on constate que dans la vraie vie c'est
pas tout à fait ça et donc on gère par
la crise par des arrêtés sécheresses de
restriction à Laval et ça c'est quelque
chose qui est pas bon parce que si vous
voulez vraiment vous organiser et vous
adapter vous avez besoin de lisibilité
sur la quantité d'eau que vous allez
pouvoir utiliser au moins 8 années sur
10 et donc ce qu'on essaye de faire avec
nos systèmes de gestion structurel de
l'eau aujourd'hui c'est de garantir une
eau huit années sur 10 ce qui permet
d'investir ce qui permet à valoir des
prêts ce qui permet d'avoir un modèle
économique
et on ne gère en période de crise que
deux années sur 10
aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas je veux
dire on a la moitié des territoires
français vous avez des arrêté
sécheresses 10 années sur 10 donc ça
veut dire qu'on
un peu par facilité on attribue plus
d'autorisation que ce qu'on a vraiment
et on gère par la crise et avale et ça
c'est un sujet qui est vraiment
important
deuxième chose faut penser au modèle
économique en fait l'eau c'est une
partie d'un modèle économique et
imaginez que il suffit que les autres
investissent pour que moi j'ai l'eau
gratuitement c'est un truc qui marche un
petit moment mais n'est pas durable dans
le temps et donc l'eau en elle-même est
gratuite et donc c'est bien le service
pour la reportable amener la transporter
la rendre disponible que l'on paye que
ce soit pour l'eau potable ou pour les
autres usages
il faut le prendre en compte et je vais
encore une parenthèse pour le monde
agricole mais mais je veux dire si vous
êtes à plus de 40 centimes du mètre cube
pour le agricole ça marche plus dans le
modèle économie agriculture donc dire on
va faire des retenues et puis ça va leur
coûter 5 euros du mètre cube je veux
dire votre modèle économique agricole ne
tient pas donc après on peut dire c'est
la collectivité qui va payer pour que
l'agriculteur et le gratuitement
pourquoi pas c'est un choix politique
que l'on doit faire dans nos territoires
et voyez
si on oublie la partie économique en
fait on se comprend pas et on oublie une
donnée du problème et donc il faut qu'on
assume collectivement que si on veut
certains usages à certains endroits et
que pour ça il faut de l'investissement
sous forme de retenue ou d'autres choses
et bien il faut qu'on prenne en compte
ses coûts et qu'on valide et qu'on
assume la façon dont on va répartir ses
coûts entre ce que fait la puissance
publique ce que fait la collectivité ce
que font les activités économiques dans
le territoire et ça c'est un point très
important qu'on a du mal à partager
souvent
j'ai encore deux idées après je m'arrête
même
la première c'est faut pas opposer ce
que certains appellent créer de la
ressources en eau enfin en tout cas moi
aussi et des économies il va falloir
faire des économies aujourd'hui comme on
a pas assez d'eau par rapport à
l'ensemble des usages il faut que cette
eau elle soit le plus utile possible et
donc on peut pas la gaspiller quel que
soit l'usage et donc il faut que dans
tous nos modèles et toutes nos
utilisations on soit le plus efficient
possible et donc souvent j'entends enfin
on a envie de séparer soit on fait
économies en impression ça serait sûr ça
suffira pas soit on va créer des
retenues et ça va résoudre tous les
problèmes c'est pas vrai non plus et
donc il faut bien partir sur ce panel de
solutions parallèle et les faire
ensemble et la dernière chose et je
m'arrête là pour l'instant c'est le les
solutions font des sur la nature l'idée
derrière
on a eu un alors moi qui suis ingénieur
ça me parle mais
on a longtemps pensé qu'on était plus
fort que la nature on pouvait s'exonérer
de la nature
et donc vous manquez d'eau vous allez
faire des retenues vous avez dit
inondations vous allez faire des
barrages ou des digues et puis ça va
bien se passer
vous avez un sol trop haut vous allez
mettre des engrais vous avez des
bestioles qui bouffent vous aimez des
pesticides enfin etc et en fait la
nature se rappelle à notre bon souvenir
quand même régulièrement et le
changement climatique n'est qu'un moyen
parmi l'ensemble pour se rappeler à
notre bon souvenir et donc vivre contre
la nature indépend de la nature n'est
pas un système qui est durable et je
crois qu'on le voit tous les jours
aujourd'hui et donc l'idée c'est de
réapprendre à vivre avec la nature alors
c'est ce qu'on appelle nous sur les
solutions fondées pour la nature c'est
reprendre comment fonctionne ces
écosystèmes et utiliser ces écosystèmes
pour ce qu'on a envie de produire et
donc
en vrai dans le domaine de l'eau
c'est des choses un peu évidentes mais
je pense qu'il faut le redire c'est
penser que en
rectifiant les rivières drainant
accélérant le truc les flux et l'Orient
le vit à la mer ça sera mieux c'est pas
vrai il faut plutôt retenir l'eau
l'infiltrer donc avoir des surfaces
d'infiltration donc des infrastructures
écologiques des bandes en herbées des
rivières qui metent pour que l'eau elle
puisse descendre des zones ça stocke
l'eau quand elle tombe et notamment en
hiver et ça la restitue quand tu en as
moins et donc si on veut avoir des
plantes qui poussent l'été vous avez
intérêt à stocker l'eau en hiver et la
meilleure bassine c'est celle qui est
sous nos pieds et parce que ça s'évapore
pas quand tu es sous nos pieds et ça se
restitue progressivement et donc
réapprendre que que l'écosystème vivant
il est plus résilient et nous permet de
mieux nous adapter c'est pas
complètement évident au premier abord
mais c'est quand même ça qui nous permet
de trouver des solutions et donc
vivre avec la nature c'est une part de
la solution hyper importante si on veut
s'adapter à l'évolution de nos climat
bon merci Monsieur le Directeur je vais
donner la parole à Monsieur Mathieu
merci monsieur le Président
bonjour mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs vous dire
d'abord que je suis accompagné d'Anne
Ducrest qui est la directrice des
opérations de Veolia en France qui
pourra vous donner et on a pensé que
c'était important vous donner quelques
retours vraiment de terrain de ce qu'on
a vécu cet été alors dans le notre
propos liminaire d'abord vous remercier
de l'invitation qui est faite à Veolia
d'intervenir dans cette commission
Veolia ofFrance distribue l'eau pour un
Français sur trois on a 15000 salariés
sur le territoire on gère plusieurs
milliers de d'usines de traitement d'eau
et on est évidemment très très concerné
par tous ces sujets de la politique de
l'eau
moi je partage complètement le
diagnostic qui a été posé par les
solutions qui ont été évoquées par mes
les deux prédécesseurs Olivier Thibault
et Thierry caquet
on a eu un été qui a été en effet très
très difficile
et qui annonce les suivants parce que
quand vous regardez ce que disent les
experts on pense à Météo France et à
d'autres
dans un horizon de d'une vingtaine
d'années l'été 2022 ce sera la
représentation d'un été sur trois en
France et donc on va arriver dans un
dans un si on voulait renforcer la
sensibilisation du public on aurait
presque envie de dire on va arriver dans
des dans des températures et dans des
climats semi-arides ce que nos voisins
européens en tout cas on pense à ceux du
Sud et notamment à l'Espagne et un peu à
l'Italie ont vécu quelques années avant
nous
donc nous notre conviction et je
laisserai Anne développer ce qu'elle
avait ce qu'elle a vécu est-ce que ses
équipes ont vécu en gestion de crise de
cet été elle est que en effet il y a une
nouvelle donne que le alors le la prise
de conscience des citoyens est en train
de s'opérer parce qu'il est évident
qu'on peut pas passer des étés déjà
l'été qu'on a vécu plus
regarder les JT tous les jours qui nous
parlent de l'eau sans une prise de
conscience les Français il y avait il y
a une vingtaine d'années il y en avait à
peu près un sur trois qui craignait un
manque d'eau dans dans sa région
aujourd'hui c'est plus du double donc
cette prise de conscience elle est
importante et c'est pour ça qu'il est
important pour toutes les parties
prenantes de la politique de l'eau de la
renforcer et de trouver les bonnes
solutions alors évidemment très
satisfait de voir que dans le dans les
plans du gouvernement le premier plan
qui a été annoncé et on l'attend avec
impatience évidemment et celui qui
concerne l'eau nous conviction elle est
multiple elle est que d'une part il faut
évidemment réinvestir sur les services
publics d'eau et d'assainissement on l'a
fait insuffisamment il y a eu le critère
d'Alert qui a été celui du
renouvellement des canalisations vous
peut-être connaissez ce chiffre qui dit
que 0,7 % des canalisations sont
renouvelées chaque année ce qui est
l'équivalent de durée de vie théorique
des canalisations d'à peu près 150 ans
donc ça c'est pas une réalité mais c'est
surtout une vision du
sous-investissement et une fois qu'on a
cette alerte sur le sous-investissement
la réponse n'est pas il faut partout et
en tout temps multiplié par deux ou par
trois le les investissements elle est
beaucoup plus ciblée
Olivier Thibault a eu 100 fois raison de
souligner que ce sont des sujets locaux
et temporels très important la
temporalité elle est pas assez prise en
compte dans les lois
si vous regardez par exemple
l'interdiction de faire des
tarifications dégressives de la de l'eau
et ben vous allez voir en zone de Zr
faut pas faire de tarification
dégressive et c'est évidemment
souhaitable mais ça ne dit rien de la
temporalité et comme l'a dit Olivier
parfois il y a trop d'eau et puis
parfois il y en a pas assez
et puis on pense que il faut réinvestir
il faut
aider les collectivités à le faire c'est
un grand sujet c'est à dire comment
est-ce qu'on déclenche l'acte
d'investissement
il y a une forme de tyrannie du prix de
l'eau en effet qu'il faut réussir à dont
il faudrait réussir à s'en à se sortir
et puis il faut aider les collectivités
certainement avec plus de programmation
publique locale peut-être que on vit
aussi aujourd'hui
les effets retours de du retrait des DDA
des DDE de l'ingénieur public qui fait
que les collectivités sont moins
accompagnées dans leurs investissements
et quand on parle d'interconnexion des
réseaux il y en a beaucoup qui se sont
faites à cette époque là parce que il y
avait un intérêt à mailler le territoire
et puis et puis dernier point on pense
qu'il faut développer la culture de la
responsabilité c'est indispensable
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui comme on est
dans une avec une ressource qui est
limitée chaque acteur qui va prélever
sur la ressource
doit s'engager à quelque chose c'est à
dire que on voit bien l'engagement qu'on
peut attendre du monde agricole qui est
à la fois d'ailleurs de mieux compter
l'eau de faire évoluer les les process
de culture de mieux irriguer d'être plus
précautionneux d'avoir plus de sobriété
le monde industriel est aussi sous
pression on a eu beaucoup de retours
d'industrie après l'été qui sont venus
nous voir ou d'activité économiques
diverses les on peut pas parler des
golfs des activités tourisme des
activités de kayak de bon qui sont venus
nous voir en disant comment est-ce qu'on
va faire pour continuer à développer nos
activités comment est-ce qu'on va faire
pour continuer à planter aussi sur les
territoires les industries dont la
France a besoin et donc la culture de
responsabilité elle est tous les acteurs
et y compris les acteurs de la gestion
et on le prend pour notre compte de la
gestion des services publics d'eau et
des collectivités là aussi évidemment
que l'alimentation en eau potable est un
prélèvement prioritaire dans les nappes
on peut pas dire autre chose mais ça
oblige quand même et ça oblige notamment
à limiter les pertes en eaux aujourd'hui
ah n'en parlera mais vous savez qu'il y
a un litre sur 5 qui est perdu c'est pas
une mauvaise il faut le dire c'est pas
un mauvais rendement comparé à nos
voisins européens mais on peut faire
beaucoup mieux et on peut faire beaucoup
mieux notamment dans des zones où il y a
encore 50% de fuite et donc j'ai envie
de dire quand il y a 50 % de 8 on a
quand même du mal en période de
sécheresse aller évoquer la priorité
absolue du service public d'eau par
rapport à d'autres donc ça oblige aussi
à progresser il y a beaucoup de réformes
qui vont aller dans ce sens là
bonjour mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs donc je fais un
Ducrest en charge de la direction des
opérations pour Veolia ou France je vais
vous dire quelques mots sur les textes
que nous avons vécu et puis les
solutions technologiques que nous
travaillons avec nos collectivités
clientes la première chose c'est que cet
été a été effectivement un été très
différent des précédents beaucoup plus
intense ce qui avait chez nous une vraie
inquiétude pour l'avenir nos équipes ont
été extrêmement mobilisées sur les
crises cet été nous avons été amenés
aussi à faire des supports entre nos
équipes régionales d'une région à
l'autre pour pouvoir faire face à cet
été particulier
j'ajouterai aux questions disponibilités
de ressources et de risques de rupture
d'eau les incendies qui mobilisent quand
même l'accès à l'eau et
pardon les incendies enfin voilà
ce que j'ajouterai les enjeux que nous
avons rencontrés c'est d'une part
l'accès à la ressource la disponibilité
de l'eau mais aussi je tiens à le dire
la qualité de l'eau parce que lorsque
les aussi des fleuves baissent et bien
les polluants sont concentrés plus
concentrés plus difficiles à traiter
lorsque la température de la ressource
augmente les polluants sont plus
difficiles à traiter et nous avons
besoin de mettre beaucoup plus de
réactifs et des effets secondaires sur
la qualité de l'eau derrière donc une
vraie inquiétude sur non seulement la
disponibilité mais le la qualité du
traitement de l'eau par la suite alors
pour aller très vite quelques éléments
de solution Olivier Thibault a cité les
sujets d'interconnexion qui permettent
de secourir un territoire avec un autre
et c'est important parce que comme vous
le savez l'eau est territoriale et n'est
pas national et donc on n'a pas de flux
simple les autres solutions la première
chose c'est travailler sur le rendement
de réseau Tristan Mathieu l'évoquait
aujourd'hui la moyenne du rendement de
réseau est autour de 79 à 80%
nationalement dans nos services on
attend 82% ces trois points de rendement
de réseau ça représente 150 millions de
mètres cubes chaque année ce n'est pas
négligeable on ira jamais
100% mais on peut atteindre des niveaux
jusqu'à 82% en mobilisant de la
technologie
des solutions digitales qui nous
permettent de suivre en temps réel et
d'identifier plus facilement les zones
ou des fuites sont à réparer évidemment
il faut faire des investissements
derrière on mobilise aussi d'autres
types de technologie avec de la
recherche de fuite par satellite par
exemple mais on mobilise aussi des
solutions parce que j'ai les
qualifierais de fonder sur la nature en
tout cas avec en utilisant la capacité
des chiens par exemple à repérer des
fuites dans certaines situations donc on
cherche des solutions technologiques et
humaines pour arriver à résoudre et
c'est un premier enjeu le deuxième enjeu
c'est la sobriété la sobriété des
usagers
l'été dernier enfin l'année dernière
pardon donc nous avons nos équipons
aujourd'hui Veolia en France et près de
3 millions 8 de compteurs qui sont télé
relevés ou radio relevés ce qui permet
de suivre les consommations des
personnes et de leur donner la capacité
à repérer leur fuite et par nos équipes
nos équipes aussi signalent ces fuites
aux usagers l'année dernière ce sont 70
72000 fuites qui ont été signalés chez
des usagers ce qui a permis d'économiser
quand même 4 millions de mètres cubes
donc on a des solutions aussi en
mobilisant les usagers et en les
accompagnant avec de la technologie
comme le télévé et puis une autre
solution c'est chercher les ressources
alternatives la réutilisation des eaux
usées nous avons lancé l'année dernière
un grand plan de mobilisation sur une
centaine de sites que nous avons
identifiés sur cette centaine de sites
en mettant en place des solutions de
réutilisation des eaux usées à la maille
du site on imagine pouvoir déjà
économiser 3 millions de mètres cubes
c'est toujours ça mais il faudrait aller
beaucoup plus loin sur la réutilisation
des eaux usées là on est sur des usages
locaux on pourrait travailler sur la
réutilisation vers de l'agriculture ou
vers d'autres usages juste pour se
situer l'Espagne est aujourd'hui après
de 15% de réutilisation des eaux usées
là où en France nous n'y sommes pas le
climat de l'Espagne sera le climat de la
France demain et donc il faut nous
préparer à cela et nous investissons sur
des solutions de réutilisation des eaux
usées nos exploitants six formes nos
ingénieurs s'y forme nos chercheurs y
travaillent et puis le dernier point que
je citerai quand même puisque Olivier la
cité les solutions fondées sur la nature
nous bénéficions aussi de l'expérience
d'autres pays pour utiliser ces
solutions bien sûr il faut faire de la
nature neutraliée nous ne sommes pas là
pour faire de la technologie à tout
craint nous sommes là pour assurer que
dans la durée nous ayons ensemble de la
ressource et de la capacité à fournir en
particulier de l'eau potable mais aussi
les autres usages voilà je vous remercie
pour votre écoute nous sommes prêts à
répondre à vos questions merci je vais
donner la parole à Guillaume chev
merci monsieur le Président merci aux
intervenants cette table ronde sur la
résilience hydrique est parfaitement
dans l'actualité puisque le ministre
présente aujourd'hui a fait une
conférence sur la le plan sobriété ou
du gouvernement face à cet été 2022 avec
ses 700 communes qui ont connu des
dichotultés d'approvisionnement en eau
potable et puis les prévisions du GIEC
qui ont été rappelés avec une baisse du
niveau des cours d'eau entre 10 et 40%
d'ici 2050 donc il faut il faut agir
tout ce que vous avez dit d'ailleurs
recoupe beaucoup de propos qu'on peut
tenir dans cette commission sur la
nécessité d'investir davantage dans les
réseaux d'avoir davantage de financement
public et d'accompagnement pour les
collectivités locales et on avait
d'ailleurs eu l'occasion d'en parler aux
ministres dans le débat préalable à la
loi de finances et j'avais posé la
question sur ce qu'il faudra une
nouvelle loi sur l'eau c'est alors par
rapport à tout ce que vous avez dit les
uns et les autres sur le territoire la
gouvernance le ministre a dit que non
pas de nouvelles lois sur l'eau mais si
on veut politiser le sujet de l'eau
un débat législatif permet de le faire
alors quel est votre position par
rapport à cette question d'une nouvelle
loi sur l'eau pour mettre en oeuvre
justement la planification écologique
autour autour de l'eau et puis faire en
sorte de simplifier le Sénat lance
également les états généraux de la
simplification aussi on a entendu
beaucoup de monde où il est nécessaire
dans la nébuleuse autour de l'eau de
simplifier
une question et pour Veolia mais vous
l'avez un peu abordé mais ce que vous
pouvez développer sur tout ce que les
travaux que vous entreprenez en termes
de recherche et développement pour
améliorer l'Efficient c'est la rendement
des réseaux et notamment l'utilisation
de de nouvelles technologies le pilotage
informatisé enfin là aussi on a besoin
d'avoir des informations
optimistes sur ces questions là et puis
également ce qui est engagé pour
réduire les nouvelles sources de
pollution je pense notamment aux
microplastiques et résidus médicamenteux
qui qui inquiète beaucoup nos
concitoyens et les locaux en particulier
bon vous avez évoqué la réutilisation de
l'eau je pense que beaucoup de collègues
vous interrogeront sur cette question là
également mais je pense qui est
important que vous puissiez développer
pour pour que en France on avance sur
ces questions là et puis pour terminer
pour mettre de l'eau au moulin pour
reprendre la formule le Président je
voudrais profiter de la présence de
Monsieur Thibault pour évoquer le sujet
de la continuité écologique et pour qui
nous fasse état un petit peu de sa
perception du sujet depuis l'adoption de
l'article du fameux article 49 de la loi
climat et résilient dans le contexte ou
la France cherche un densifier le
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
alors comment
de votre position nationale vous avez vu
évoluer le dialogue entre
l'administration et les propriétaires
d'ouvrages hydrauliques des difficultés
subsistent-elles je suppose et est-ce
que des études plus approfondie sur les
incidences des ouvrages hydrauliques
hydroélectriques dont elle était lancée
comme le recommandait un rapport que que
le Sénat avait produit d'ailleurs en
mars 2021 et sur un sujet connexe le
médiateur de l'hydroélectrique a été
nommé le 9 décembre dernier pour la
région
Occitanie là pour qui a pour mission
d'aplanir les difficultés concernant une
installation hydroélectrique autorisée
ou un projet est-ce que vous jugez que
ce type de solution est utile sachant
que dans la CMP sur les EnR il est prévu
une extension sur le niveau national là
aussi est-ce que vous pouvez faire part
de votre observation sur cette question
merci
[Musique]
et je vais regrouper un certain nombre
de questions et puis vous répondrez j'ai
la parole à Monsieur Denis
merci monsieur le Président merci aux
différents intervenants
moi je voudrais vous parler de nos
agriculteurs qui sont en première ligne
face aux pénuries et qui vous savez sont
garants de notre souveraineté
alimentaire les projections climatiques
semblent montrer qu'à terme sur
l'ensemble du territoire la diminution
des cours d'eau sera de 10 à 40% pour
une majorité de bassins les conclusions
du varen agricole de l'eau 2022 ont
d'ailleurs souligné d'urgence d'agir en
identifiant l'ensemble des leviers dont
la création de nouvelles réserves de
récupération des eaux pluviales alors
Monsieur Thibault vous avez parlé de
d'adaptation tout à l'heure on évoque
d'autres ressources possibles comme par
exemple la réutilisation des eaux usées
madame on a parlé il y a un instant que
pensez-vous de cette de cette idée et
d'une façon plus générale quelles sont
les concertations que vous menez les
mesures que vous envisagez de prendre
pour mieux inclure les les acteurs du
monde agricole territoire par territoire
je l'ai bien compris dans la gestion de
cette ressource en eau
merci la parole est à monsieur bonjour
merci monsieur le Président tous les
quatre moi je voudrais vous parler prix
du mètre cube d'eau
après des tarifs relativement stable ces
dernières années l'eau comme les autres
ressources fait face à une envolée des
prix au 1er janvier de nombreuses
collectivités syndicats ont été obligés
de voter des hausses de tarifs
quelquefois très élevé sur le prix de
l'eau cette hausse est souvent expliquée
par la mise en oeuvre de processus
énergivor dans la partie mécanique par
exemple effectivement le pompage de
l'eau la cheminement et l'usage de
produits dont le coût a augmenté lié
avec l'augmentation du coût du pétrole
les augmentations qui ont été annoncées
par les différentes collectivités
locales vont de 6 à 12% par rapport au
prix de référence
et en fonction de cette fourchette on
peut en déduire que globalement une
famille moyenne en France voit le coût
annuel de l'augmentation du prix de
l'eau potable aujourd'hui de l'ordre de
40 à 60 euros de plus alors vous avez
parlé ici de explorer enfin je ne sais
pas votre système qui permet non c'est
pas explorer c'est ça qui permet de
projeter l'avenir alors moi je vous
interroge je voudrais savoir vous
pourriez vous nous indiquer quelle
vision prospective vous avez sur
l'augmentation qui va avoir lieu du
mètre cube d'eau en France et la logique
c'est peut-on arriver à une explosion
d'ici 5 ou 10 ans du prix du mètre cube
je n'ai pas trouvé de chiffres pour
l'année 2023 évidemment 2022 non plus en
2018 le prix moyen en France du mètre
cube d'eau était de 4,8 combien était-il
en
2022 et si vous pouvez projeter ce que
ce sera dans 5 à 10 ans
merci la parole est à Monsieur gold
merci monsieur le Président merci pour
les propos des uns et des autres alors
moi je vais surtout vous parler
rendements des réseaux et puis échelle
territoriale chaque année principalement
en période estivale on assiste comme
vous l'avez rappelé les uns et les
autres à de nombreux problèmes
d'alimentation en eau potable dans
certaines communes ou partie de communes
on est obligé de mettre en place des
rotations de camion-citerne ce qui
demande évidemment aux élus une
rationalisation de l'eau disponible mais
aussi le règlement de factures
importantes les différents modes de
gestion engendré des investissements
plus ou moins prononcés et qui n'ont
jamais été à la hauteur des besoins ce
qui n'est pas sans conséquence donc sur
le rendement des réseaux aujourd'hui
beaucoup de départements font le choix
de syndicats d'alimentation en eau
potable donc au niveau territorial au
niveau du département
ce qui permet de d'interconnecter les
réseaux et de bénéficier d'une eau de
qualité en quantité disponible partout
pour certains cette solidarité est mal
vécue car il existe un sentiment que les
meilleurs élèves paient pour ceux qui
n'ont jamais investi dans leur réseau
moi j'aimerais donc savoir pour vous
quel est l'échelon territorial le plus
adapté à une gestion publique de l'eau
ou bien il y a-t-il des niveaux du si
vous n'êtes pas capable de me dire quel
est le meilleur et je chante territorial
y a-t-il des niveaux en tous les cas à
éviter pour que les investissements
soient garantis avec un rendement bien
sûr optimal des réseaux je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Madame Perrot
merci messieurs merci Président j'ai
quelques réflexions les retenues d'eau
douce les bassines sont à chaque mise en
place conflit entre les habitants les
agriculteurs les pêcheurs les chasseurs
pourtant mon département possède 5000
hectares de réservoirs d'eau douce et
réservoir scène et aube
abritant une très grande biodiversité il
existe des territoires comme chez moi
dans plusieurs endroits de France qui ne
demandent qu'à servir d'exemple alors
pourquoi l'État ne se sert-il pas plus
de ce qu'il possède pour démontrer
prouver entre autres qu'une retenue
d'eau deviendra avec le temps une
superbe réserve d'eau et mais aussi
biodiversité et éviter ainsi les
conflits qui ralentissent le
développement des territoires autre
chose aussi les drainages des prairies
pour en faire des terres céréalières ces
catastrophiques ces catastrophiques
aujourd'hui pour les plantes mais aussi
pour le bâti car les prairies
entouraient les villages et servaient de
tampons évit ainsi des dérangements
importants dans le bâti et ça on le voit
de plus en plus et aussi une autre
réflexion
dans mon département un syndicat d’eau a
été créé en 1943 par des élus
précurseurs et c'est vrai que nous avons
quand même une gestion des des réseaux
et de la distribution d'eau qui est
quand même de bonne qualité
merci et puis pour terminer cette série
de cette série de questions j'ai donné
la parole à Madame Bonnefoy
merci Président je voudrais remercier
aussi nos intervenants pour la qualité
de leur intervention ce jeudi à Jarnac
en Charente mon département a été
présenté la stratégie de résilience à
l'horizon 2050 par l'établissement
public territorial du bassin du fleuve
Charente le territoire s'organise donc
pour s'adapter au changement climatique
et définir une stratégie de long terme
est-ce que vous avez eu connaissance de
cette étude globale qui fourmille de
propositions d'adaptation et qui répond
à ce que disait tout à l'heure un
monsieur Thibault je tiens donc à saluer
cette démarche qui est une démarche
prospective et participative qui redonne
à l'eau son caractère essentiel à savoir
qu'elle fait partie du patrimoine commun
de la nation je suis d'ailleurs très
attaché à cette notion qui est définie
dans le code de l'environnement car elle
permet de garantir la maîtrise publique
de la gestion de l'eau
à l'heure où nous connaissons des
tensions sans précédent sur cette
ressource il est donc impérieux de
refonder nos usages de l'incitation à
l'aménagement du territoire prenons par
exemple la question de la zéro
artificialisation nette que nous
examinerons prochainement ce sujet est
étroitement lié à la gestion de l'eau en
matière d'infiltration de l'adéquation
besoin ressources ou encore de la
préservation des continuités écologiques
donc quel est votre point de vue sur
l'artificialisation
l'articulation pardon entre le zan et la
gestion de l'eau ce changement de
paradigme doit être entendu par
l'ensemble des usagers et des décideurs
ainsi comme nos collègues de la
délégation à la prospective je suis
David repolitiser l'eau en redonnant aux
élus la capacité technique d'arbitrer
les choix stratégiques sur la
répartition des usages de la ressource
en eau sur les usages agricoles
notamment si nous voulons éviter les
conflits à venir je suis pour développer
un organisme unique de gestion
collective qui aurait
en charge la gestion la répartition des
volumes d'eau prélevés à usage agricole
sur un territoire déterminé ainsi
l'accès à l'eau serait recentré dans une
instance décisionnelle unique ce qui
aurait l'avantage selon moi de replacer
au centre de la ressource un acteur
public et de facilité une vraie
transition agroécologique indispensable
à une gestion plus économe ainsi qu'à
une meilleure qualité de l'eau sur ce
sujet de la transition agricole comment
envisagez-vous l'outil des paiements
pour service environnementaux dont
quelques agences de l'eau se sont saisis
pour emmener le tissu agricole dans un
cercle virtuel de bonne pratique c'est
le cas par exemple pour haut du bassin
rennais que vous devez connaître que
pensez-vous de la démarche initiée par
la métropole de Poitiers ou de Poitiers
pardon de Montpellier visant à mettre en
place une bonne tarification de l'eau le
système qui est en train en vigueur le
1er janvier dernier consiste vous le
savez certainement après à préserver
gratuitement les 15 premiers mètre cube
d'eau potable ensuite le prix augmente
en fonction de la consommation d'eau
l'idée c'est de récompenser les familles
les plus économes et de sanctionner
celles qui sont les plus grosses
consommatrices et que est-ce que vous
considérez que cette innovation est une
démarche à reproduire et dernière
question que pensez-vous de donner une
personnalité juridique à des cours d'eau
merci
je vous propose de de répondre mais pas
à répondre chacun à toutes les questions
de cibler les réponses que vous voulez
donner à mes collègues merci
un certain nombre pour l'administration
quand même de questions là
alors il y a des choses où je vais être
courbe monsieur Chevrollier mon ministre
a par nature raison donc si Sidi qui a
pas besoin de loi il y a pas besoin de
voir
et donc voilà
ce dont je suis sûr
il y aura des sujets législatifs
après faut-il qu'il y ait une loi
spécifique sur l'eau ça c'est un sujet
politique qui n'appartient qu'à mon
ministre mais sur les sujets législatifs
vous parlerez d'eau ne serait-ce que
dans les lois de finances parce que
fiscalité des sujets de plafond des
sujets de redevance qui qui vont revenir
ce que dit mon ministre et pour le coup
je pense que c'est important c'est que
il faut agir tout de suite il faut pas
attendre et donc imaginer que lancer
maintenant un grand débat pour
construire une nouvelle grande loi sur
l'eau dans deux trois ans ça risque de
nous freiner ou de nous ralentir pour
trois quatre cinq ans alors qu'en fait
il y a plein de choses à faire
maintenant tout de suite et donc son
choix c'est le choix de l'action et donc
c'est aussi ça la planification
écologique avec à la fois du moyen du
long terme je pense qu'il y aura des
choses législatives quand même dans qui
qui viendront mais il faut agir tout de
suite et il y a plein de choses qui
peuvent se faire avec le le cadre
réglement enfin législatif que l'on a
aujourd'hui en bougeant un peu le cas
réglementaire on le simplifiant en
libérant un peu les territoires voilà le
la façon cela continuité écologique
[Musique]
et donc là c'est toujours des histoires
de coup bénéfices c'est à dire
enfin partout on pouvait faire des
grands barrages rentables on les a fait
en fait et on les a fait il y a
longtemps et il s'agit pas de les
détruire il s'agit plutôt des optimiser
parce que en renouvelant le matériel en
fait on peut gagner quand même pas mal
de puissance installées
et donc après il faut faire attention à
pour gagner quelques kilowatts en plus
ne pas aller détruire des réservoirs
biologiques voilà donc la position de
l'administration aujourd'hui c'est de
dire on a des cours d'eau classés les
coraux classiciens c'est 7% du
territoire alors on peut dire que c'est
trop on peut dire que c'est pas assez
enfin en tout cas c'est 7% du territoire
et on essaye de sauvegarder si c'est 7%
du de continuité écologique sur ces
territoires bon c'est pas apaisé on n'a
pas trouvé les bons outils pour le
partager pour trouver les moyens
d'investir d'accompagner comme il faut
donc dans vos questions il y avait le
médiateur moi je pense que c'est une
très bonne chose parce que partout on va
réussir à mettre des gens qui vont
permettre à chaque partie pendant de se
parler et trouver de manière le plus
rationnelle possible les solutions parce
qu'il y en a des solutions
bah écoute il faut il faut il faut y
aller et donc la généralisation de ce
médiateur ça va arriver un peu plus vite
que ce qu'on avait imaginé au départ
mais enfin bon je pense que ça ça peut
pas être une mauvaise chose et pour moi
ce qui est important
encore une fois je l'ai déjà dit tout à
l'heure c'est il faut que les gens aient
une visibilité sur ce qui s'impose et
sur les contraintes qu'on a je trouve
que le pire c'est de laisser croire
qu'il y a pas de contrainte laissez
investir et puis après ramené les
contraintes ou et donc quand on a la
visibilité des contraintes qu'on a sur
certaines parties du territoire on
l'intègre dans son modèle économique on
sait qu'il faudra faire une passe à
poisson c'est qu'il faudra faire une
rivière contournement des fois on sait
que il faudra faire attention à pas
turbiner à certaines parties de l'année
quand les annonces descendent vraiment
des choses comme ça
et à partir de là ça permet d'avoir la
visibilité et donc d'investir voilà donc
encore une fois mais ça vous le savez on
essaye de pas opposer ces politiques on
essaie de les concilier et c'est
objectivement pas facile alors après ce
demi sur l'agriculture
là aussi il faut concilier les usages
et l'agriculture est absolument
essentielle dans notre système y compris
pour les biodiversité ça je le redis
souvent aussi je veux dire aujourd'hui
on a une biodiversité qui va pas bien
des courbes qui sont pas dans le bon
sens alors ça va plutôt pas trop mal
dans les forêts moins bien dans les
grandes plaines enfin je veux dire si je
fais un peu caricatural et simple
donc ce dont on a besoin c'est d'avoir
de l'agriculture compatible avec les
enjeux environnementaux qu'on a dans ces
territoires et donc c'est pas n'importe
quelle écriture n'importe où donc
aujourd'hui quand on dit conciliation
des usages je veux dire l'agriculture
que l'on met dans nos bassins
d'alimentation des captages d'eau
potable je veux dire c'est mieux si elle
pollue pas trop l'eau à la main pour
éviter d'avoir investi un des sommes
énormes pour traiter l'eau après ça veut
pas dire pas d'agriculture dans le
Carthage
ça veut dire une agriculture avec moins
d'un an de l'élevage extensif ça marche
très bien des systèmes avec des haies
des prairies ça marche très bien de
l'agriculture biologique ça marche bien
enfin et donc on a tout un tas de choses
qui sont totalement compatibles et donc
l'enjeu pour nous c'est d'avoir les
outils d'accompagnement de l'agriculture
pour contenir la bonne à la bonne
l'agriculture compatible avec les enjeux
du territoire dont on parle et donc on
va pas dire la même chose dans la bosse
à des endroits où il y a pas de sujets
d'eau à des endroits où on est dans le
périmètre de captage à des endroits où
il y a personne et donc il y a pas de
problème enfin etc et derrière ici une
question qui a été posée derrière enfin
plus tard enfin c'est Madame Bonnefoy
moi j'y crois beaucoup au paiement par
service environnementaux je pense que
c'est une partie de la solution c'est à
dire qu'on a un système pour
l'agriculture et des mesures
agro-environnementales climatiques dans
le pilier 2 de la PAC ça on indemnise
une perte de rendement et ça marche pour
certaines choses quand on veut baisser
une enfin je parle de fréquence de
traitement quand on veut forcer à avoir
un sens de choses qui font perdre du
rendements les paiements pour services
orientaux c'est un truc complémentaire
il y a mon avis qu'il faut développer
plus ou là on va rémunérer explicitement
des actions qu'on veut faire porter par
des parties qui peuvent être des
agriculteurs pour faire des choses qui
vont être une bonne pour l'environnement
et ça c'est quelque chose qui marche
très bien
donc pour le coup j'ai une attachement
particulier parce que j'ai personne en
participé au poids la première
notification de ces paiements pour
services en même temps quand j'étais à
l'agence de Loire toi Picardie
on me disait à l'époque ça
n'intéresserait jamais les agriculteurs
parce que c'était en faire des
jardiniers du paysage ou des choses
comme ça ça super bien marché parce que
on arrive à rencontrer notre public et
puis ça donne du sens à ce qu'on fait on
fait pas semblant de payer par une un
truc qui n'est pas une Mae et donc moi
j'y crois beaucoup il faut pas que ce
soit fait n'importe comment et c'est
aussi un moyen de rendre compétitif
certains usages qui sont ça
disparaîtront parce que si à la fin on
perd notre agriculture ça renvoie la
souveraineté alimentaire il faut quand
même qu'on arrive à se nourrir mais il
faut aussi qu'on boive enfin je veux
dire et donc faut réussir réconcilier
tout ça
sur la réutilisation des eaux usées on
est mauvais
mais faut faire attention dans les
comparaisons avec les voisins d'à côté
parce que certes en Espagne ils sont à
18% mais quand vous avez plus d'eau dans
la rivière et que vous utilisez l'eau
des session d'épuration pour aller
directement irriguer les équations
agricoles à côté en France on a encore
un peu d'eau dans les rivières mais on
fait de la réutilisation cachée en fait
c'est à dire que quand vous regardez les
débits des cours d'eau de nos rivières
en été j'ai plein d'endroits on monte à
40%, 50% du débit c'est l'eau des
stations d'épuration dans le sud encore
plus que dans le Nord bon en fait les
agriculteurs ils pompent cette eau dans
les rivières on n'appelle pas ça de la
réutilisation des eaux usées mais si on
s'amusait à sortir cette eau des
stations d'épuration et l'utiliser
directement sur de l'agriculture vous
arriveriez vous devriez supprimer des
pompes pages qui aujourd'hui sont dans
la rivière
vous voyez donc il faut faire un peu
attention à ces chiffres une fois qu'on
a dit ça on est à moins de 1%, je veux
dire il faut qu'on change de braquet sur
la réalisation des eaux usées donc là
derrière c'est là encore un sujet un
poil compliqué parce que dans l'eau il
s'est jamais complètement simple
il y a un enjeu sanitaire fort et
aujourd'hui ce qui nous bloque dans le
développement c'est les enjeux
sanitaires c'est c'est on a appris et on
a appris l'habitude en France
de ne pas se poser de questions quand on
a de l'eau elle doit forcément être
potable pour tout ce qu'on a autour de
nous et à partir de là chaque fois que
vous allez autoriser de l'eau il faut
qu'elle soit potable et donc c'est ce
qu'on a mis derrière ce qu'on appelle
les usages domestiques mais je peux vous
donner des exemples qu'on vit tous les
jours moi j'ai des collectivités qui
peuvent pas arroser leur pelouse de foot
parce que
on nous dit que mais si un gamin vient
lécher la pelouse il peut tomber malade
si l'eau est pas potable donc il faut
mieux arroser la pelouse avec de l'eau
potable je veux dire c'est des
raisonnements comme ça qu'on a et donc
là il faut qu'on
réapprenne à se dire
que toute l'eau n'est pas potable toute
l'eau n'a pas forcément élevé et qu'il y
a des fois il faut faire attention et
une fois qu'on sait ça et ben on peut se
permettre des usages non potable et donc
ça c'est vrai pour l'arrosage des
espaces verts des pelouses des jardins
municipaux des philosophes etc et le
sujet aujourd'hui il est sur cette
conciliation entre la notion de risque
sur les usages et
voilà après il y a un petit sujet
économique aussi parce que il y a des
endroits où ça se développe pas parce
qu'elle est trop chère de l'eau
usée retraités et bien plus cher que de
l'eau gratuite dans la rivière à côté
donc
il faut aussi accepter de payer au juste
prix le qu'on utilise et si c'est pas
l'usager qui le paye il faut bien
quelqu'un le paye il s'appelle la
collectivité mais ça renvoie ce sujet
tout à l'heure
alors Monsieur rejoint sur le prix de
l'eau
moi je
ça fait pas forcément toujours plaisir
mais je pense que le prix de l'eau en
France n'est pas aujourd'hui à son juste
prix je suis persuadé
que si on est rationnel et si on veut
dans la durée répondre aux enjeux qui
sont devant nous il va falloir augmenter
un peu ce prix de l'eau alors ça veut
pas dire l'augmenter pour
alimenter des trésorerie ou des grandes
entreprises c'est c'est le prix de l'eau
doit correspondre au service rendu et ce
service rendu
ça doit permettre d'entretenir le
patrimoine première chose et permet de
distribuer une eau potable à la fin
quand on parle de l'eau potable et donc
ce qui me paraît hyper important
c'est
c'est de bien identifier le service
qu'on veut avoir d'identifier combien ça
coûte et d'avoir un prix qui est
cohérent avec ce service qu'on a envie
d'avoir et donc derrière dans un
contexte de changement climatique on a
besoin d'interconnexion on a besoin de
solutions de secours on a besoin
de réseau en suffisamment bonne qualité
et donc ça ça a un certain coût et c'est
vrai que l'énergie enfin a largement
augmenté donc ça a augmenté une fois
qu'on a dit ça
et c'est un point important il y a eu la
loi brode puis après on a élargi le
système il faut être capable d'apporter
des réponses à nos concitoyens les plus
fragiles parce que le vrai sujet de
l'eau c'est pas qu'elle est chère ou pas
cher je veux dire deux tiers des
Français savent pas combien il paye
l'eau
aujourd'hui encore je veux dire
non mais c'est vrai et puis c'est cruel
parce que enfin moi qui vit dans le
monde de l'autre depuis 20 ans je veux
dire j'ai l'impression que c'est évident
mais en fait non donc on sait pas alors
pourquoi on sait pas d'abord tous ceux
qui sont dans les habitat collectifs
voient pas de factures d'eau donc ça
passe trop ce que c'est et puis derrière
quand vous êtes en dessous de 1% de de
votre revenu en fait c'est pas ça qui va
vous contraindre ou qui va vous piloter
dans la façon dont vous allez gérer
votre budget
si on dépasse les 3% si on est passé
imposant là ça devient un vrai sujet et
donc vous avez des populations qui sont
fragiles pour lesquelles le prix de
l'eau devient un sujet et donc là c'est
l'histoire de la tarification
écologique progressive et solidaire donc
il faut que ce soit progressif parce que
dans notre monde un peu je veux dire
consumériste tout ce qui n'a pas de prix
ne vaut rien et donc de l'eau gratuite
on la gaspille donc il faut que ça aille
quand même un certain coût si on veut
l'utiliser rationnellement et donc ceux
qui en utilisent beaucoup
quand même légitime qui paye plus mais
après il faut des forces de rappel donc
c'est la partie solidaire pour que ceux
qui n'ont pas la capacité de le payer
puisse avoir une aide et là c'est au
choix des collectivités aujourd'hui
les premiers métiers gratuits c'est une
possibilité un chèque eau c'est une
autre possibilité enfin je veux dire
c'est au choix des collectivités par
contre si on met pas en place ces
mécanismes de solidarité
derrière on va exclure une partie de nos
populations et ça c'est quand même un
vrai problème vous voyez donc pour moi
le prix d'eau il a plutôt vocation à
augmenter un peu parce que le service
dont on a besoin est plus important que
ce qu'on pouvait dire il y a 10 ans et
il faut des mécanismes solidaires
aujourd'hui non mais ça tu le diras un
peu mais il va le dire vous inquiétez
pas mais je pourrais vous le dire mais
oui ça va augmenter alors
sur le syndicat des parcs cantaldo
pour moi la question que j'ai un peu dit
tout à l'heure la vraie question c'est
quel service voulait avoir aujourd'hui
une commune toute seule notamment tes
deux réseaux
qui a une ressource fragile est en
situation où elle va avoir des problèmes
on sait pas si c'est aujourd'hui demain
etc donc il faut construire des
solutions plus résilientes et donc
voilà donc la commune toute seule pour
moi c'est en général trop fragile et
c'est un problème deuxième chose il vous
faut un service à taille critique un
service à ta critique ça veut dire qu'il
vous faut des gens compétents que vous
êtes capable de rémunérer quand vous
avez une commune de 600 habitants elle
n'est pas capable d'avoir un service
rémunéré à la bonne échelle ça c'est une
réalité après que ce soit un syndicat
d’eau que ce soit une communauté commune
une communauté d'agglomération je veux
dire ça dépend du territoire mais il
faut la taille critique pour avoir une
capacité d'investissement une capacité
de réaction une capacité permettant de
6e de crise et d'avoir les gens dont
c'est le métier voilà le modèle où vous
avez la jambe municipale qui va mettre
une passive de chlore dans le château
d'eau une fois par semaine et c'est ça
le service de haut c'est un truc qui a
marché pendant 50 ans qui qui n'est pas
durable voilà que ce soit départemental
ou EPCI
moi je pense c'est pas à nous de le dire
dans un département très rural ça
souvent du sens d'aller à l'échelle
départementale dans un département
urbain en général ça n'a pas de sens et
donc c'est ça qu'il faut regarder et là
encore une fois c'est les élus qui
doivent trouver le bon système c'est
vrai que la transition est pénible quand
on est une commune qui investie et qu'on
va se mettre avec la commune d'à côté
qui a pas investi c'est très frustrant
quand on a une commune qui a un prix de
l'auba et que celle d'à côté a prévu
l'harmonisation est un moment difficile
mais mais il faut se dire que si on veut
un système qui tienne dans le temps il
faut avoir la taille qui va bien
je m'arrête petit j'ai dit les PSE enfin
j'ai plein de choses à dire encore mais
je vais vous partager un peu allez-y
merci beaucoup ben je vais je vais pas
reprendre tous les points qu'après
Olivier avec qui je suis totalement en
accord moi je voudrais peut-être en
préambule revenir sur un mot que vous
avez utilisé en terme de thématique pour
vos travaux c'est le mot de résilience
je pense qu'on en a pas discuté mais
c'est un sujet sur lequel on pourrait
débattre pendant des heures parce qu'on
n'a pas tous les mêmes définitions et
vision de ce qu'est la résilience en
tout cas si je me place du point de vue
de l'agriculture telle que inrae promeut
la transition agroécologique une
agriculture résiliente si on est en
aucun cas l'agriculture d'hier même
d'aujourd'hui l'agriculture en 2030 elle
sera différente et elle sera résiliente
en ce sens qu'elle continuera à produire
vraisemblablement différemment
probablement des quantités différentes
mais en tout cas il y a toujours une
activité de production qui se maintient
et on ne vise pas
systématiquement le rendement maximum
comme on a pu le faire pendant des
dizaines d'années avec des
justifications qui à l'époque pouvait
sembler valide mais elle est plutôt et
c'est vrai pour l'usage de l'eau
notamment en agriculture j'en viens
réponse à certaines questions c'est de
se dire que une irrigation
indispensable on le sait dans certaines
régions d'ores et déjà et qui va devenir
de plus en plus importante si on veut
maintenir une simplement maintenir je
parle pas de maximiser une activité
agricole devra viser cette obligation de
résilience donc maintient d'une
sécurisation de la production et non
plus d'une maximalisation de la
production je pense que c'est un message
qu'on essaie de faire passer parce que
ça veut dire que derrière les systèmes
de production ils doivent évoluer dans
le respect des agriculteurs et dans le
respect du revenu des agriculteurs
l'idée c'est quand même que les gens
puissent continuer à vivre même si
actuellement c'est difficile pour un
grand nombre d'entre eux de leur métier
et puissent contribuer à la production
alimentaire donc c'est vraiment une
changement profond de gérer de viser
c'est pas la maximalisation c'est la
sécurisation en tout cas l'irrigation
pour nous une réelle est vue de ce point
de vue là alors par rapport à Monsieur
de Minnie qui évoquait effectivement le
varen de l'eau je crois vous l'avez
évoqué bon j'ai beaucoup participé
notamment sur la thématique 2 qui était
justement sur le thème des agriculteurs
de résilience et en fait le levier de
par deux entre 2021 et 2022 et ça
continue à augmenter parce que le
pompage bah c'est de l'énergie ça coûte
ça coûte de l'argent et donc c'est
levier qu'on a qu'on a commencé à
identifier dans le cas du varen de l'eau
on les mobilise actuellement dans un
exercice notamment de préparation de la
prochaine loi d'orientation agricole
sous l'impulsion de Marco vous savez
sans doute il y a trois grands groupes
de travail qui ont été mobilisés sur la
formation l'autre sur la transmission et
l'installation et le dernier sur
l'adaptation de l'agriculture au
changement climatique et donc on
réutilise les travaux du varen pour la
mise en cohérence des différents leviers
parce que c'est un message que j'essaye
de porter quand j'interviens sur ces
sujets il y a pas un levier unique si il
y en avait un on le saurait et on
l'utiliserait donc c'est les
combinaisons de leviers qui vont être à
mobiliser et ça a été une remarque qui a
été faite sur l'approche départementale
je crois que c'est Madame Bonnefoy qui
l'évoquait
c'est vraiment à l'échelle des
territoires des bassins de production
que se passe les choses alors on peut
avoir une vision alors je peux revenir
sur le débat nouvelle loi sur l'eau mais
je pense qu'on a déjà un arsenal
législatif et vous êtes bien placé pour
le savoir qui est très conséquent qui
est pas forcément toujours utilisé ou
appliqué et donc déjà si on appliquait
l'ensemble des dispositifs ça pourrait
déjà peut-être dégager des solutions
mais en tout cas la prise en main à
l'échelle des territoires de ces
exercices de prospectives alors
départementale régional les régions font
aussi beaucoup de choses sur ces
notamment nouvelle Aquitaine pour
prolonger par rapport à la Charente a
fait ce genre de choses depuis très
longtemps sur l'adaptation du massif de
Gascogne pour la forêt etc et je pense
que c'est une des solutions il est par
l'appropriation de la part des acteurs
et de tous les acteurs ça a été dit pas
que les agriculteurs tous les citoyens
sont concernés doivent se sentir
concernés et être effectivement mobilisé
par des exercices on va dire
participatif dans le bon sens du terme
d'échanges et de partage d'une vision
commune pour pour les territoires et sur
la question de la l'articulation avec
personnes et gestion de l'eau c'est
évident je l'ai évoqué rapidement en
introduction ralentir le cycle de l'eau
ça te dit aussi par Olivier Thibault
favoriser l'infiltration avec par
exemple ce fameux solution fondée sur la
nature ce sont des choses qui se doivent
être considérées comme des solutions
sans regret puisque effectivement la
meilleure eau c'est celle qu'on va
pouvoir capter sur le territoire et
infiltrer lorsque c'est possible parce
que celle-là va être protégée contre des
altérations de qualité parce que nous
qu'on stocke un plein air elle évolue
dans sa qualité elle peut dégrader et
puis on fait aussi des pertes par
l'évaporation donc vraiment c'est
important le drainage des prairies
madame pero évoquait ça c'est évident
que pour nous enfin même si pendant
longtemps les agronomes on prôné un
certain nombre d'actions de drainer des
prairies et altérer des prairies ou des
espaces culturels assez très important
faut l'éviter alors pour l'eau mais
aussi pour l'athénomination du
changement climatique parce que des
prairies qui fonctionnent mal c'est
aussi des stocks de carbone en moins
faut quand même le retenir quant à la
question des barrages réservoirs va
effectivement puis des espaces Ramsa
qu'on a pu maintenant installer sur des
Grands Lacs à l'est de c'est quelque
chose bon dont on peut faire la
promotion après faut voir que ces
barrages réservoirs ont été installés
dans les années Jérémy 1960 si je me
souviens bien
la situation hydrologique à venir elle
est pas du tout la même donc méfiance
par rapport à ce qui pourrait être une
projection et puis pour terminer puisque
cela réutilisation c'était beaucoup
balayée par Olivier sur la question de
des retenues et de se dire des modèles
qu'on peut aller voir ailleurs qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont fait bon on passe de la
Réunion
on parle beaucoup de l'Espagne
effectivement l'Espagne a anticipé
semble-t-il un certain nombre de choses
deux points là-dessus c'est une démarche
qui a été axée surtout sur satisfaire à
la demande donc un pilotage par la
demande et non pas par l'offre or là on
est dans une situation où l'offre
drastiquement se réduire au moins
localement et puis quand vous regardez
les ouvrages hydrauliques en Espagne bah
un bon nombre maintenant on a beaucoup
de mal à les remplir parce que une année
sur trois voire deux années sur trois il
y a pas assez d'eau donc c'est
temporairement peut-être j'irai une
solution mais sans une solution qui
permet de reconcevoir le système donc
c'est temporairement utile ça coûte de
l'argent et à long terme ce n'est pas
durable voilà ce que je voulais dire sur
ces différentes questions
merci
merci Michel le Président on va se
partager le notre temps de parole avec
Anne Ducrest je prends un peu les
questions dans le désordre mais sur le
sur le prix de l'eau aujourd'hui le prix
de l'eau en France en moyenne et c'est
le 6PA qui nous le dit c'est 4 euros 30
du mètre cube de commentaires par
rapport à ça d'une part l'assainissement
aujourd'hui coûte plus cher que l'eau
potable donc de depuis quelques petites
années mais on a vu quand même cette
montée là
deuxième élément Candy 4,30 € faut pas
oublier que pour nos concitoyens ça veut
toujours dire que avec un centime
d'euros on a quand même 2,5 litres et
donc c'est à la fois j'ai envie de dire
cher quand il y a une abondance d'eau et
pas cher quand il y en a plus mais par
comparaison ces derniers jours il y a eu
pendant des annonces à Bruxelles qui ont
annoncé la deuxième augmentation de 15%
ils ont fait plus qu'un pour cent 2022 +
15 % de 2023 le prix de l'eau il va être
autour de 6 euros 6, du mètre cube quand
on va en Allemagne c'est à peu près les
mêmes niveaux qu'on va au pays etc donc
moi je partage complètement l'analyse de
d'Olivier qui est de dire que de toute
façon il y a des besoins qui vont avoir
un impact sur le prix de l'eau que ça
renforce ça doit renforcer les aspects
de d'aide au plus démunis que ça doit
renforcer aussi peut-être le fait de se
partager un peu l'effort et et de pas
tout faire porter non plus sur le
consommateur d'eau je un petit clin
d'oeil c'est de rappeler que par exemple
la TVA sur le la TVA sur le sur
l'assainissement et de 10 ou 11% pendant
que celle sur l'eau potable et à 5,5 si
jamais l'État avait la bonne idée de
d'aligner les deux TVA ça permettrait à
la baisse évidemment ça permettrait de
ça permettrait de dégager un peu de
capacité de financement pour les pour
les collectivités d'alléger un peu la la
facture toujours est-il que ça veut dire
que dans ces moments de tension on a
besoin de plus de solidarité vis-à-vis
des plus démunis et de plus d'efficacité
la solidarité vis-à-vis des plus démunis
on n'a pas d'avis sur les différents
systèmes madame la sénatrice évoquait la
gratuité des premiers mètres cubes mais
et Olivier Thibault évoquait l'écheco ou
la tarification sociale une chose est
sûre c'est qu'il y en a une ou deux qui
sont très ciblées et l'autre qui ne
l'est pas donc quand on fait la première
la gratuité des premiers mètres cubes on
sait pas vraiment à qui ça bénéficie en
tout cas ce n'est pas une mesure sociale
puisque rien ne dit que c'est
redistributif entre des gens plus aisés
des gens moins aisés et là aussi il faut
se méfier toujours de ce qu'on peut
tirer de la tarification parce que on
n'est pas capable de savoir ce qu'il y a
derrière une consommation d'eau c'est à
dire que il y a parfois des familles
nombreuses qui vont consommer plus d'eau
et puis parfois des familles ou des
foyers mono mono-personnes qui vont
plutôt gaspiller donc je crois que ce
qui est important dans la politique de
l'eau c'est bien cibler nous on est là
pour aider les collectivités on a parlé
tout à l'heure de la digitalisation des
services publics de la du nombre de
compteurs communicants ça typiquement ça
permet par exemple de faire des
tarifications saisonnière qui dans des
périodes de fortes tensions sur l'eau
donne un signal prix pour essayer de
faire en sorte que que les les
consommations soient moindres sur le
sujet Riot là aussi complètement
d'accord avec ce que dit le directeur de
l'eau
et j'ajoute quand même un bémol c'est
que ce qui nous vient à l'esprit c'est
que évidemment quand l'eau de la station
d'épuration est rejetée en mer ou dans
l'océan là on a quand même tout intérêt
à leur retenir une fois de plus sur
terre et donc en veoliao développe un
nombre de la réutilisation des eaux
usées à Bonifacio pour des activités de
tourisme et que ça représente en gros la
consommation de la ville de Bonifacio au
mois d'août et ben je pense que c'est
favorable au territoire plutôt que
d'aller rejeter directement cette eau
douce dans une mer d'eau salée et on
pourrait dire la même chose de ce qu'on
fait à Sainte-Maxime ou peut-être qu'à
nous dire quelques mots du projet
vendéen dernier point c'est pas à nous
de dire si il faut ou non une loi sur
l'eau une chose est sûre c'est que la la
musique de l'eau elle a été souvent trop
mise en silo et qu'il faut la défiloter
c'est à dire qu'il faut parler à
l'agriculture il faut parler à
l'urbanisme faut parler à l'industrie et
que nous en tout cas quand vous nous
annoncez un effort de simplification de
la législation moi je vois toujours un
clignotant qui est celui justement des
autorisations sur la réutilisation des
eaux usées traitées quand vous parlez à
des gens sur les territoires des élus ou
des opérateurs ou des industriels qui
essayent de mettre en œuvre ce genre de
de ce genre de projet ils ont en face de
cinq ou six administrations ou alors il
dit bah alors on passe par la clé après
il y a la RS après il y a le coder c'est
après il y a il y a le préfet et puis
tout le monde se renvoie la balle et
c'est ce qui fait qu'on met 10 ans pour
développer ce genre de projet donc un
projet moi qui me tient à coeur de
simplification c'est celui par exemple
de la création d'un guichet unique dans
les départements qui va être capable de
traiter les dossiers et d'apporter de
l'expertise aux élus locaux qui veulent
développer ce type de solutions et du
bon sens
parce que j'ai encore dignement de
l'intervention
mais en 2 minutes très rapide juste un
mot sur le prix de l'eau vous avez
signalé
qu'effectivement le prix de l'augmenter
sous l'effet de l'énergie ça nous
rappelle qu'il faut de l'électricité
pour produire de l'eau les risques de
délestage auquel on a dont on a parlé
au mois de décembre et en début d'année
sont effectivement aussi évidents sur
les services d'eau et d'assainissement
et oui c'est pour ça qu'il faut aussi
travailler sur l'efficacité énergétique
des services d'eau juste quelques mots
chez Veolia nous visons à baisser de 5%
nos consommations énergétiques pour les
services d'eau et d'assainissement nous
exploitons 5% en deux ans c'est un grand
programme pour essayer de travailler sur
notre efficacité énergétique efficacité
aussi qui doit se faire sur les produits
de traitement sur la réutilisation des
eaux usées juste quelques mots il y a
une valeur agronomique dans l'eau qui
sort des stations d'épurations et donc
il y a pas qu'une valeur de quantité il
y a une valeur de qualité et cette
valeur agronomique peut être apportée
aux agriculteurs il y a un certain
nombre d'expérimentation qui existe et
qui montre que c'est utile et c'est
particulièrement utile la di Tristan en
zone littorale où il y a effectivement
c'est dommage que l'eau partait à la mer
sur les autres usages il y a l'eau
industriel sur site et ça nous l'avons
déjà démarré il y a également les eaux
de lavage par exemple dans la rue voilà
il y a également la protection de la
ressource elle-même l'exemple de
Jourdain qui vise à utiliser les eaux
usées pour recharger la ressource après
en passant une petite zone de solution
fondée sur la nature également pour
utiliser la capacité purgatoire du
milieu c'est un très beau programme qui
permet de travailler sur l'accès à l'eau
en Vendée et ce programme se développe
et il faut pouvoir développer ce type de
programme mais il y a aussi par exemple
utilisation d'eau usées pour faire une
barrière hydraulique pour protéger par
exemple les nappes de la remontée du
biseau salée parce que si vous injectez
de l'eau et bien vous empêchez l'eau
salée d'aller polluer les ressources
existantes donc on a beaucoup d'options
sur la réutilisation des eaux usées et
il faut continuer à poursuivre ce
développement en levant comme l'a dit
Tristan les barrières administratives et
réglementaires sachant que les Français
sont prêts puisque classiquement ils
pensent déjà que l'eau qui arrive au
robinet vient directement de la station
d'épuration donc rassurons-nous tout le
monde est prêt et la crise de cet été a
rajouté de la capacité de
d'acceptabilité de ces sujets là je vais
rebondir sur le fait territorial pour
répondre à la question sur la
réutilisation des eaux usées dans
certaines situations en fait c'est
toujours une solution locale qu'il faut
trouver si l'eau n'est pas disponible
elle n'est pas disponible louisée n'est
pas disponible il faut trouver d'autres
solutions mais vraiment c'est toujours
on va pas trouver ici des solutions
générales ça se ça se regarde vraiment à
la maille territoriale en fonction des
situations pour répondre à la question
madame de masse sur la technologie pour
les réseaux oui on peut utiliser on
déploie des capteurs des capteurs qui
peuvent écouter les fuites des capteurs
par les compteurs qui permettent de
suivre les consommations on a même
maintenant des compteurs qui peuvent
repérer les fuites donc on arrive à
travaillant sur l'instrumentation donc
en investissant sur de l'instrumentation
à travailler sur les réseaux ceci est en
croisé avec un traitement des données de
l'intelligence artificielle des jumeaux
numériques je vous lâche un peu tous ces
mots mais il y a beaucoup de solutions
qu'on peut continuer à développer et
qu'on développe en solution
opérationnelle et ensuite il faut
évidemment des gens pour aller réparer
et l'investissement on en a déjà parlé
l'investissement il doit aussi se faire
dans les usines pour répondre à la
question sur les micropolluants une de
nos inquiétudes je les signalé au début
baisse du niveau des du niveau des
nappes et baisse des débits dans les
fleuves égale concentration en polluants
et puis l'arrivée de molécules rémanente
qu'on voit apparaître de plus en plus et
qu'on repère de plus en plus ça nous
amène à mettre en oeuvre des traitements
il faut penser encore à ça les solutions
on en a les charbons actifs peuvent être
utilisés on a des solutions de
microfiltration de nanofiltration
d'ultrafiltration voire d'osmose inverse
qui permettent de traiter de plus en
plus ces polluants et face à nécessite
aussi des investissement et c'est pas
toujours de gaieté de coeur parce qu'on
n'a pas forcément envie mais parfois on
a que cette solution sur la
désalinisation au regard l'équilibre
économique n'est pas toujours là je vais
pas citer l'Espagne qui a des solutions
de dessins animations en tout cas ça
fait partie des solutions qui existent
mais il faut qu'on cherche aussi les
autres solutions dans un premier temps
sur les usagers enfin en effet la
sensibilisation est importante là aussi
des solutions digitales nous aident je
vous donnerai juste un exemple on a une
application mobile aujourd'hui nous
avons 800 000 abonnés qui se connectent
sur leur application mobile entre 5 et 6
fois par an pour suivre leur
consommation ça c'est un vrai apport
parce que ça aide aussi les gens à
entrer dans la situation c'est c'est
aussi une solution qui existe on a
environ 2 millions 8 aussi de connexion
sur notre agence en ligne ça fait partie
des des outils qui aident les gens à
bouger sur la prise en compte de l'eau
dans leur quotidien voilà ce que je
voulais dire être en une minute pour
compléter pour répondre sur le sujet
aussi des agences de l'eau
je dirais même enfin dans la lignée de
aussi des de l'affichage et de la
demande de de la Fédération des
Entreprises de l'eau pour nous le
plafond mordant ce n'est vraiment pas
une bonne nouvelle évidemment parce que
l'eau a besoin de ressources et et c'est
un flux qui manque c'est un flux
financier qui manque à l'eau donc on
s'associe complètement
au président notamment des comités de
bassin qui en demande de le la
suppression ça nous semble une évidence
il y a pas il y a pas lieu j'irai de
faire la poche ou les poches des agences
de l'eau en ce moment
on voit d'ailleurs d'un très bon œil
tout ce qui est tout ce qui incite un
peu plus à la et reconnaît un peu plus
la performance des territoires c'est à
dire que on a quand même des témoignages
des locaux vous en avez peut-être
également ou certainement également qui
disent on essaye d'être plutôt dans les
bons élèves mais on a du mal à être
reconnu et finalement entre une gestion
améliorée ou une gestion un peu dégradée
on voit pas beaucoup de différence et on
regarde donc avec intérêt et avec et on
accueille favorablement aussi des
projets qui visent à réinjecter un peu
pas énormément mais un peu de
performance dans le calcul des
redevances des agences de l'eau vous
allez dire bah oui bah ceux qui font des
efforts sur le rendement de réseau sur
les fuites sur la sur l'assainissement
ça ça a de la valeur et pour prolonger
le discours d'Anne du Crès on est
persuadé d'une chose c'est que c'est un
ensemble de solutions qui font mettre en
œuvre et le pire que qui a crame la
politique de l'eau c'est finalement
c'est confrontation entre ceux qui
diront c'est les SSN les autres qui
diront non c'est la ryotes les 3e c'est
la techno non il va falloir de tout pour
faire face à une situation qui est quand
même préoccupante
je suis présent si vous permettez juste
revenir sur une question que Monsieur
Favreau a posé sur les nappes
effectivement c'est un vrai sujet alors
deux éléments de réponse à cela si on se
projette dans le futur les modélisations
dont on a parlé montre la recharge de
nappes va être de plus en plus difficile
en terme quantitatif parce que des
cumuls de sécheresse sur plusieurs
années en fait ce qui impacte le plus
toutes les notes fonctionnent pas la
même façon entre la nappe de beau ce que
vous évoquiez les nappes qui sont très
reliées aux rivières par exemple en
Deux-Sèvres Charentes c'est pas du tout
le même fonctionnement mais globalement
les sécheresses cumulées sur plusieurs
années
conduisent au fait que la nappe peut se
recharger en hiver mais finalement
progressivement on a de moins en moins
un niveau nappe qui baisse et il y a le
problème de la qualité que vous avez
évoqué ça te dit par plusieurs
intervenants c'est qu'on va concentrer
aussi un certain nombre de contaminants
dans les nappes qui ont une durée de vie
très longue dans les sols on retrouve
encore à l'heure actuelle des résidus ou
de produits de la trazine par exemple
qui est interdit depuis très très
longtemps et la déetti la traze des
isopropylène trazinnes on la retrouve et
un la retrouvera encore pendant très
longtemps parce que c'est des produits
il y a pas de dégradation une fois que
c'est arrivé dans les nappes le problème
du nitrate que vous évoquez et d'autres
éléments on pourra en citer beaucoup et
donc non seulement c'est une question de
quantité mais une question de qualité et
donc une ressource dans la qualité se
dégrade les usages qu'on peut en faire à
coup constant il y en a de moins en
moins et si on veut faire des usages
on est au consacrant plus d'argent ça va
être possible mais ça va coûter de plus
en plus cher donc le niveau des nappes
c'est quelque chose de critique c'est
une ressource effectivement donc
favoriser l'infiltration d'eau on l'a
dit à plusieurs fois c'est vraiment une
solution sans regret encore faut-il
parce que c'est tant qu'on a un filtre
soit une autre bonne qualité on va pas
voilà donc il y a un problème de qualité
mais c'est quand même extrait
extrêmement important et ça fait partie
du panel de solution encore une fois il
y a pas il y a pas une solution unique
sur ces sujets là
quelques derniers éléments pour répondre
aux questions que mes voisins n'ont pas
complètement répondu
[Musique]
la première chose sur le moyen des
agences de l'eau
et puis derrière sur ce qui va être
annoncé ou et qui sera annoncé demain
pas pour aujourd'hui donc
ce que j'ai envie de dire c'est d'abord
vous avez une certaine malice à montrer
nos contradictions c'est le jeu mais il
y a une certaine constance des
gouvernements successifs sur les agences
de l'eau qu'on peut que noter
aujourd'hui je veux dire ça fait quatre
gouvernements que ça baisse que qu'il y
a un plafond et et ce que je note
aujourd'hui
ce que je note aujourd'hui est-ce que
montre les groupes de travail qu'on a pu
mener sur la planification écologique de
l'eau c'est qu'on a un moment où on
prend conscience qui va falloir changer
quelque chose
[Musique]